what's up you guys
time for a movie retrospective
so this one okay so i was like kind of
interested the one reason i put this one
in the poll i had actually never seen it
before
but i was thinking well it's about jack
the ripper
[ __ ] crazy ass klaus kanski is in it
and it was directed by jess franco and i
don't think we've done any jess franco
movies previously and it's free on tubey
so i figured hey like what the hell
now i'm gonna say
i didn't love it movies aren't watchable
i didn't love it it looks good but it's
just not watchable well interesting
yeah well the okay the thing about it um
i don't know like i feel like a lot of
people that come to this channel are
probably pretty familiar with jess
franco but if you're not he was he was a
spanish director
um probably one of the most prolific
filmmakers uh in modern history he made
almost 200 films sometimes as many as
nine in a single year
um very famous for exploitation cinema
you know he would do [ __ ] like you know
nunsploitation he did he made like
vampires lesbos uh the awful dr orlov
which this movie is a little bit kind of
like a remake of but yeah so
he's like really known for doing that
kind of like trash exploitation kind of
[ __ ] now that said
this movie though
looks really nice yeah it's like
expensive and honestly i mean it's not
he didn't spend a lot of money on it but
this actually i saw one review that said
this actually looks more like a real
movie than anything that like jeff
branco ever made i don't know if that's
down to the cinematographer or whatever
it is but
it's a little bit different than his
usual stuff
and
the thing that you have to know about
this is that even though it's called
jack the ripper and klaus kinski is
playing a jack the ripper like product
um it's not this has nothing to do with
the actual jack the ripper other than it
being like a surgeon type thing him
killing prostitutes and it ostensibly
being set in london even though they
actually shot it in zurich
um it's like it has nothing to do with
uh with it now the thing about it was
like it started out pretty cool like i
said it looks beautiful it almost looks
like a hammer film yeah it's just a
serial killer movie but yeah it does not
have anything to do with the white
chapel or the or the type of victimology
or the actual case this is just let's
just make a serial killer movie that's
what they're talking about and they set
it in that era
mother the edit is unwatchable if you
ask me boring
[ __ ] it has good elements but they're
just not presented right
it kind of drags in certain areas and
[ __ ] klaus is just stale as [ __ ]
through the whole thing just stale i
mean
you could probably edit klaus to be a
lot more interesting
with what was shot but not the way it's
shown just long drawn out scenes of his
face and you start laughing at it
you start laughing yeah they're [ __ ]
trolling you you know the thing about
like some horror fans really dig this
like people that are really into jess
franco and stuff even though like i said
this isn't exactly what jess it's a
little bit classier than what jess
franco usually did now this does have
like some extreme gore and like a lot of
nudity and rape and [ __ ] like that in it
but
you would think with it being jess
franco and see this is what i was
thinking like before i saw it you would
think with it being jess franco and with
it being klaus kinski who is you know
well-known crazy person [ __ ]
crazy and um i heard some i don't know
if this is true or not but i there were
allegations that he had actually like
abused and possibly even raped like one
or both of his daughters
uh i'm not sure you did this clouds
cancel i didn't realize it yeah uh i'm
not sure if that's the case or not it's
just something that i came across while
i was like reading other reviews of this
but
the thing about it is like i kind of
figured if you give klaus kinski a role
like this where he's supposed to be a
creep you would think that he would just
like go out there and be crazy but he's
not he's very restrained now some of
that might be because he's dubbed yeah
uh he's dubbed over that's not his real
voice what they did with this was i
guess they filmed they filmed it like i
said in switzerland um with a mostly
swiss crew as far as i'm aware and maybe
like some germans
but what they did was i guess just like
in italy they had everybody kind of talk
in their regular voices and then they
dubbed everything over like they did an
english dub and a french dub and a
german dub and whatever the hell um is
the eu dub yeah so well yeah so they can
show it in lots of different markets
because there's like a huge market for
these kind of like sleazy kind of films
over there yeah the countries are little
man you can't sell a movie in one
country in europe it's got to be for all
of them yeah you got to do like you got
to dub it in all the languages so like i
said that's kind of why italy like why
giallo films and stuff like that that's
why they just didn't even bother like
everybody just speak whatever language
you speak
and then we'll dub it over later into
all the different languages it's
probably just easier to do that which
sometimes worked out
sometimes
it did yeah i didn't love it here though
like i said because klaus kinski has
such a distinctive
voice and i think that his voice is like
something to do with his persona this is
kind of like when they overdubbed udokir
in suspiria which wasn't as big a deal
because you know he had like a tiny part
in that but it's kind of the same thing
it's like if you're going to watch
udokir or if you're going to watch klaus
kinski part of what you want to see
about them is their voices i mean that's
like so much part of their persona so
the fact that he's dubbed over by
an english or scottish actor
is kind of like a little off-putting
yeah
now she just mentioned udokir if you
want to see a real trippy [ __ ] horror
flick watch kudo curious frankenstein
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] mind-blowing it's
diametrically opposed uh to this movie
this movie
we did a review of it but although we
never did andy warhol's dracula either
have we which has essentially the same
cast oh yeah we did the the frankenstein
one is better but frankenstein's great
it's [ __ ] perverse it's [ __ ]
weird as [ __ ] it's where uh uh that the
character [ __ ]
uh uh uh
from sprockets came from was it dieter
from sprockets he's definitely doing
udokir from that movie stop don't touch
my monkey you're loving him too much
you're spoiling him it's in there all
right
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] good flick this
one
it had gore it had nudity it had a
madman
a real madman [ __ ] in the movie you
know
that was [ __ ] right there a real
actual man an actual man man
and it still managed to be boring
uh yeah it was really like a shame yeah
it was really a shame and it had a lot
of good plot elements you know [ __ ]
uh um
the ripper has basically a female simp
that does whatever he wants her to do it
takes care of all the bodies and totally
loved him that was [ __ ] weird that
was a weird element but they never
really did much with it
it that was kind of like my biggest
issue with it was that like a lot of
i mean that was a fascinating aspect
yeah
of the story
that like i said this has nothing to do
with the real jack the ripper murders at
all so like don't think that it is it's
like it's maybe like a couple things
that are similar but yeah this
introduction of this character who is
his housekeeper wife who we don't know
it's just her stamp
she just lives there
and she knows exactly what he's what
he's doing and like watches him do it
loves him
and she goes and like dumps the um you
know the bodies and the thames and stuff
well it's not really the thames
obviously because it's uh in switzerland
but you know it's supposed to be the
times but uh she goes and at one point
like he cuts up the bodies and she goes
to like dump it in the river
and she's like
rummaging around in there and like pulls
out an eyeball like i'm gonna save that
guy for later
yeah and i kind of wish
they would have done one they shouldn't
have called this movie jack the ripper
because nothing to do with jack the
ripper i mean you could have just made
it like a generic the thing about it is
that jess franco made a movie called the
awful dr orloff
and this movie is almost a remake of
that so i kind of figure that maybe he
got like a slightly bigger budget and
he's like oh i'm gonna like remake this
movie
and the producers were like why don't
you call it jack the ripper because
that's like name recognition so he's
like yeah whatever because this is
essentially i mean the whole thing about
having the female
uh accomplice the whole thing about like
one of the cops being married to a
ballerina and like the ballerina like
going undercover to you know help to
solve the murders like all the aspects
of this movie were from
awful dr orloff and i think in jack the
ripper
i didn't see because this didn't have
any end credits and i wasn't really
paying attention at the beginning like
to the beginning credits because all the
credits were at the beginning
but in some prints of this movie jack
the ripper the character that klaus
kinsey plays
is
is uh credited as dr dennis orloff
so you can see that he's trying to make
it i think dr orloff is a character that
turned up like in a lot of jess franco
films so you can see that he's
essentially just trying to like cram
the dr orlov story like into a jack the
ripper narrative yeah and he crams a
bunch of characters that don't need to
be in there into this narrative also
you could fix this movie you'd have to
edit that oh yeah big time because it
looks beautiful yeah and actually it was
restored in 2013.
um even from what i could determine
because this is the first time i've ever
seen it from what i could determine um
you know people said even like on crappy
vhs you could still tell that it was
nicely shot
um but they said now it's it's been
restored like on blu-ray and they're
like it looks gorgeous and it does like
a lot of the shots are beautiful like a
lot of the you know just wear it with
the settings yeah the settings are
beautiful the costumes are nice like
everything you know acting isn't bad not
really yeah it's a competently made
movie you know what i mean the problems
to edit
yeah it's the editing and the fact that
there's too many plot
plot threads that are kind of just left
unresolved yeah there's no reason for it
to be in there they need to chop this
thing down and streamline the story so
it's a little faster paced uh it's all
there
you know uh you make it a slasher flick
a pretty standard flight you can make a
standard slasher flick that probably
pretty entertaining and satisfying just
out of what's there you'd probably lose
30 minutes 35 minutes of the movie
but and i don't think this movie is that
long yeah really i think i have to go
back
92 minutes it felt like it was two hours
long something like that it did feel a
little bit long i mean i kind of and i
didn't know if it was just me because i
was like really really tired
um and we didn't start it that late we
started like 8 30 and like by the time
like it was getting to the point where
the ballerina was like oh i'm gonna go
undercover as a hooker and like see if i
can draw him out or whatever because the
cops aren't doing diddly [ __ ] um i kind
of dozed off a couple of times yeah i
started to get about uh and i'm very
patient you guys know yeah i was 30
minutes into it just going uh come on
uh why are they doing this you know it's
it just it needs to be really
streamlined and chopped down into a into
a
linear coherent narrative
that is fun to watch and is not kind of
there's there's a lot of good [ __ ] in
there there is yeah but
there's so much of it that it starts
becoming tedious and what there's the
cool [ __ ] that they show you isn't going
to amount to anything later on it'll
never be
like like a typical italian flick
actually [ __ ] the giallo flick
they'll just do something you're like oh
yeah that was cool but that didn't mean
anything in the story
it's because they were sometimes it does
and sometimes it doesn't it depends on
who you're talking about italians mostly
just
the italians mostly just made the script
up as they were going they're like it
just looks cool we'll worry about it
later yeah that's the truth of giallo
movies that they were pulling it out of
their ass
although you haven't really seen that
many so i don't know no no i [ __ ]
[ __ ] saw interviews with people that
[ __ ] were you know involved in the
productions and [ __ ]
yeah i mean two a large accent yeah make
it up but some of them do make sense
yeah you know although i think sometimes
the sense is made up after the fact and
the and they've
and is the senses made in edit because
some of those guys were just that's
legit yeah some of the guys would have a
script but then as the [ __ ] would unfold
they couldn't execute that script
because the
actors would be fighting or refused to
do it so they'd have to change things
and then somebody gets six but they got
a film so they changed some other [ __ ]
and then like we'll work it all out
later let's just shoot it you know it
was that kind of stuff
and then in edit they could piece it
together and a lot of times when it was
done it was nothing like the original
script or the idea of what what it was
now it might have been good after that
you know the audience didn't know what
the original script was it didn't matter
well and the thing about it is i kind of
like a movie well depending on the
director the script is just kind of like
a jumping off spot like i know that some
directors are very especially if they
stick to the script but some directors
are just kind of like well the script
says this but why don't you just because
you know obviously making a movie is
like a large team effort so you're gonna
have like a lot of people and then like
after you finish shooting it then you
had gap to give it to an editor and yeah
i i think editors are kind of like the
unsung heroes of like the movie business
maybe it could break you they really do
make or break a movie i mean to be
honest with you yeah you have to have
the good [ __ ] there to start with but
for the editor to work with but yeah
that makes a big difference the whole
star wars [ __ ]
saga
was all saved and edit [ __ ] a new
hope because the original edit [ __ ]
sucked evidently but [ __ ] lucas's
wife free ended that [ __ ] never really
she was good i think that happens with a
lot of movies whereas like the first
original edit well because editing and
directing are kind of two different
talents i mean sometimes you get the
same you know the the same talent in the
same person
but sometimes you don't and sometimes
you need an editor to come in and go oh
we don't need that or we need to like
move this around or something like that
somebody that's not
you know creatively not creatively
invested but they didn't like write it
and they didn't direct it so they don't
maybe they have a little bit of like one
removed from it so they can kind of come
in and go yeah you don't need that or
the other thing a lot of the klaus
kinski scenes in this he seems kind of
aimless like he's not he doesn't really
know what he's supposed to do he just
puts that [ __ ] face on i don't i
think there's no plan to any of this
he's just ad libbing
you know uh which a good actor is gonna
do that but like i said we can't tell
because he's dubbed so i can't tell like
what his actual voice sounded like well
just his facial expressions and his body
language and some of these some of these
scenes is very awkward like he's not
really sure how the scene is going to go
you know it's just it's just you know
it's okay you know what's interesting is
that
you know klaus kinski famously uh he
hated well yeah but he hated directors
but him and jess franco seemed to get
along matter of fact uh klaus was in a
couple other of jess franco's movies i
think he was in the dracula movie and i
think he was in but jess franco i think
made a very loose adaptation of marquis
de sades uh justine and i think he was
in that as well so they really seemed to
get along and everyone thought that was
crazy because it's like like we thought
klaus kinski hated everybody especially
directors but him and jess franco i
don't know why they were some potico i
did not know that klaus was suspected to
having raped his daughter i didn't know
that either i saw it i talked about
natasha right i don't know if it's true
yeah i don't know if it's true i just
like saw it on another review and i was
just like holy [ __ ] i never heard that
yeah
are they referring to natasha i'm not
sure she was a cutie
yeah yeah she was an actress too yeah
you guys tasha kinski
but the thing about it okay so there's
good [ __ ] in this movie though i mean i
do like
i like the angle of like the female
accomplice i like that i wish it had
been explored more i also like and this
might be a little weird i also like that
like the main witness or even kind of
like the hero of the movie is not the
cop but it's this blind dude
who
he was there like when the first attack
in the movie happened and obviously he
can't see but he heard the woman
screaming and he smelled klaus kinski he
smelled jack the ripper okay and so he's
able to he later on he's the one that
like identifies because spoiler alert
like jack the ripper gets caught at the
end of this um you know which obviously
didn't happen in real life but yeah so
that's how he gets caught because he has
a very distinctive smell to him like
because the blind man is like telling
the cops all this stuff it's like oh
well i can tell he's an intellectual he
smells kind of like books and he smells
like this rare spice from india
and he has like all this other kind of
stuff and i was like i like that i liked
that angle because it was like a little
bit unique i also liked his uh thirsty
as [ __ ] landlady yeah that was pretty
funny i liked that whole like so i don't
know if it was meant to be yeah she was
trying to [ __ ] throw herself at him
that he didn't have to pay rent as long
as he he provided her with the service
and she wasn't ugly she was a good
looking she wanted to she wanted to jump
on the yeah she i think she was in one
of those kind of like she was she and
she wolf of the ss or something like
that i knew she was in one of those kind
of like heroes klaus is just amazingly
magnetic with women i don't know how it
happens yeah everybody like every woman
every woman in all the movies that he's
ever in trying to jump on klaus all
right
and yeah and this this movie he doesn't
approve and he doesn't approve of this
[ __ ] his face just gets more
there's he there's a lot of close-ups of
his weird ass totally disgusted by sex
totally in every well they explain it in
this movie because he has a flashback
right and the whole thing about it was
that his mom was a prostitute yeah so
that flashback of him uh where he's
laying in the bed and he sees like his
mom like wavering in front of him and
that crazy like psychedelic flashback
that he has and like she's talking about
i mean that's supposed to be his mom
right i'm pretty sure that's supposed to
be his mom like according to everything
and she's like saying that she's kind of
like implying that she's gonna like
screw him as well so yeah i think that
was his imagination though no i think
that's his mom yeah no but
he is imagining she was saying that to
him though wasn't she was not like his i
don't know if it was imagination or if
it was uh a memory
yeah you know what i mean like i i think
that the interpretation of it was that
because his mom was a hooker she was
getting everybody then that means that
he had to go and kill like hookers that
looked like her yeah and that was why
that was why there was the whole thing
about the ballet dancer um who i can't
remember if it was the same actress or
not but she looked pretty much exactly
like his mom so he'd actually been
stalking her whereas before he'd always
seemed like he was just opportunistic
like hey here's a prostitute like
walking by herself in a creepy dark
alley i'm just going to like snatch her
and take her back to my lair
all up and there's a lot of you know and
there's a lot of like gory scenes i mean
they don't look
real because the you know they have that
bright red tempera paint blood and
everything like that but you know women
get their tits cut off yeah uh arms get
cut off there's like a pretty disturbing
rape scene although it's like he's kind
of raping her and he's like stabbing her
at the same time it's kind of shot in
the middle distance or like long
distance so it's not like it looks real
but yeah so it's just kind of so there
is like some gory [ __ ] in this but
nothing looks like realist looks like
it's on at all
i was under the impressive impression
that that those flashbacks of his mom
were kind of like
part of a part of like a madonna horror
complex of how he imagined her
that's why i i interpreted it i don't
think she i mean it could have been yeah
i mean that could have been his real mom
or that could have just been he was
messed up and that's how he perceived
her yeah that's i think but i guess in
the end she was a prostitute but i think
he had perceived her as being like that
yeah i guess in the end it didn't matter
because i mean his perception was what
led him to
become a serial killer and the thing
about it too and i also liked this
aspect i did like a lot of things about
this movie i also liked the aspect that
he was almost kind of like a jekyll and
hyde type character i was gonna say that
because um
he like during the day he was a doctor
and he was absolutely willing to you
know people that were poor or couldn't
pay or whatever and he would have them
come to the office and he was like super
nice to them and he like helps them with
their stuff like i was to say that lance
and their boyles and whatever i was
going to say that maybe you said that
they shouldn't have called this jack the
ripper
when you said that earlier i was like
yeah they really just should have called
it dr jack on mr hyde it's closer to dr
jack on mr hyde that's what i was
thinking
they just should have added the drug and
they would have made a [ __ ] good dr
jekyll movie
yeah because i mean jack sadly jack the
ripper doesn't have uh hasn't cornered
the market on killing prostitutes yeah
so it's like yeah you could say it was
influenced by jack but like i said
essentially jess franco had already made
this movie called the awful doctor
orloff which was just like a regular
like a doctor that killed prostitutes um
so this is almost like a
beat for beat like remake of it just
with the jack the ripper thing tag
tacked on that's what i'm saying and i
don't think it was him i think it was
the producers like said that to do that
um because like i said the dude made
like from seven to nine films every year
so it's not like he was pouring his
heart and soul into this stuff he was
just trying to crank him out as quickly
as possible you can make some money you
could just retweet this a little bit
with edit and add a couple scenes
transformation scenes or do whatever and
turn this into [ __ ] dr jekyll
yeah
yeah i don't think i mean this it has a
lot of good elements to it like i said i
really like the blind guy thing i really
like the the female accomplice i like
that angle i like the whole
you know the ballerina like going
undercover like as a prostitute to try
and like smoke the dude out i like a lot
of [ __ ] about it like you said i think
the main problem won the dubbing i kind
of wish everybody had just kind of used
their own real voice or they would have
just put subtitles on it because i don't
really like dubbing usually um
and the edit i think it would have been
i think really those are the two main
issues with it other than that i don't
really have a problem with it yeah um
you know i i just kind of wish that
there there was a lot of good elements
that i wish had been explored more
you know
because of the edit i'm not gonna [ __ ]
with it i'm not gonna recommend it
i mean this is for experts only like i
mean if you're into jess franco if you
really love
klaus
then you see it then you should probably
see it and i have seen some horror fans
that really love this movie yeah and i
can understand that
it's just the edit is very unwieldy it's
very ponderous yeah and it's it's uh
and like i said i've been drinking and
you're you're high you just want to
[ __ ] see a klaus kinski movie you
don't really care what's going to happen
in it or how long it's going to take
then go ahead and see it but to me
everything seemed to be happening a bit
in slow motion
yeah it did kind of seem like that today
and things would happen but they're
they were interesting but then they
would never followed up on
yeah and then that's that was the
problem that was the problem right all
the interesting [ __ ] wasn't explored it
wasn't explored yeah and then like just
a lot of it was sort of these long shots
of like a prostitute like walking
through they like which which is fine
like that establishes atmosphere and
everything but i think there was too
much of that and there was just like two
and also i wish that kinski had gone
more like balls to the wall i mean
he's allowed he's a super freak and i
kind of wish he would have embraced that
especially in this role where he's going
around raping and murdering
women and like cutting their tits off
it's like
putting them up on the shelves and start
yeah like i'll just put the tits right
there you know what i mean he does that
so it's just kind of like i wish that he
had just gone more like maniacal like he
was kind of more known for he's very
very reserved in this yeah which was a
strange choice yeah and they introduced
they introduced interesting characters
and don't do anything with them like
this his simp chick [ __ ] i was like
okay where's this going to go see that's
what they don't go anywhere they don't
go anywhere with it they never explain
like why
why she's hanging out with them like why
yeah maybe it's the same thing as with
the landlady where she just thought he
had like a magic dick well maybe it's
just because because he was like grossed
out by women like the only way that he
could get off basically was by like
stabbing them because they showed like
that later on like he does rape a woman
or they they imply that he rapes her but
you can't tell if he's actually like
raping or raping her if he's just like
stabbing her like getting off on it like
that so that's the only way that he can
get a sexual release is by like stabbing
women and like cutting them up so
whenever like when the landlady
approaches him like in a normal way like
oh have some tea and blah blah like he
gets really really like uncomfortable
and aggro about it and because he just
can't like stand it the only way that he
can relate to women is by killing them
apparently like in a sexual way he seems
to like relate to his patients and stuff
like that whether they're male or female
like normal like normal
but any time like any kind of like
romantic or sexual feelings come into it
like he's like nope getting stabby so
there was that and i liked so i liked
that aspect of it but again it seemed
like most of the interesting stuff
wasn't explored as fully as it could
have been
and then some of the stuff that wasn't
as interesting like went on for too long
that was the only issue but like i said
well you know when when you think about
it this could be re-edited and maybe
redubbed
and i think it would be like salvageable
but it looks really nice the acting
seems to be good although with the
dubbing i can't really tell um but if
you re-edit this movie to make it
streamline you cut probably the best
[ __ ] out
[Laughter]
that's the only that's the only because
you'd probably end up cutting most of
the simp chick out
you'd be cutting the landlord out
probably
there's a lot of [ __ ] that would be cut
out
that was notable about the movie it's
like they it's like they followed the
wrong story
yeah that was kind of the impression
yeah because like i said as soon as
we're introduced to that woman yeah it's
just kind of we're like wait does she
know what he's up to yeah they should
have went that way but then i was like
oh this okay this is interesting what is
this all about and then they didn't
really do anything with it no and i
think the ending was a little abrupt too
because like i said pretty much the
blind guy comes there and smells them
and is like yep that's him and then like
the cops arrest him and then klaus says
um you'll never prove it
end that's it yeah there's like not even
at the end there's no end credits
there's nothing it was just i was
watching on to be and he just went
you'll never prove it and then like the
next movie popped up then i was like uh
okay but yeah so it ended very very
abruptly so yeah i mean if you're into
jess franco if you're into kind of this
euro sleaze type of [ __ ] there's some
good [ __ ] in there and it's worth
watching if you're into that
but
i wouldn't really recommend it as a
first
if you want to get into the
cinematography of jess franco it'll take
a while because you made a lot
uh this probably isn't the best place to
start because it's not that much like
his other [ __ ] like his other [ __ ] was a
lot sleazier
um i feel like this was kind of him
trying to do hammer a little bit um with
just a little bit of sleeves and more
and more yeah but i mean well his usual
stuff was pretty gory and pretty smutty
but so there is something hammer in it
yeah yeah that's well yeah that's what
he was trying to do it seemed like
hammer but with more gore and more and
bush and stuff you know what i mean like
tits getting cut off which they wouldn't
do in a hammer movie right i mean they
might do it but they would imply it they
wouldn't actually show it this one
actually shows it for you bubologists
and [ __ ] out there
you teenage booboologists teenage
pathologists the women are nowhere near
as hot as hammer hammer women though
they're a little thin yeah they're too
skinny bounty skinny
whereas yeah i do i do kind of the ones
in hammer but you want to see real women
you look a [ __ ] hat where you usually
had uh bigger boobies yeah the british
knew how to pimp the ones in here had
boobs but they were you know they they
were pretty thin women you know what i
mean no so england and england were
[ __ ] masters of booboology yeah i
mean were appreciated they
they were the predecessors to frostbite
russ meyer learned everything he knows
from [ __ ] the british yeah england is
a very it's like a boob appreciation
yeah but you know typical american
fashion you take ours went to 11.
up one more notch that's what russ
meyers yeah yeah yeah you should
probably i have his uh autobiography
it's like fascinating or a biography
that's actually like really really
interesting it's over there on the
bookshelf somewhere but yeah so this is
on to be if you feel like watching it
like i said i didn't love it i thought
it was like a little bit boring but
there is like some good [ __ ] in there so
your mileage may vary if you've seen it
let us know what you think about it in
the comments that'll do it for this
movie retrospective we'll see you guys
on the next one bye